psychologists apparently gave an  interview when he said sex with robots  will be considered normal in 50 years  yes this this yeah there it is yeah sex  with robots is is possible but elusive  and I have to tell you I have looked  into this subject long been a dream of  mine many many brave men have been  trying without success to make this  dream come true for the past century in  fact I thought it was appropriate  because it's destroying the news here's  a salute to some of those early pioneers  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you  yeah  yeah a man burned to death hey thanks  for watching be sure to click subscribe  to see even more great Conan clips you  may now return to your pirated movies  and creepy Japanese pornography